so I just saw this small Indie movie an
a24 film at South by Southwest really
solid performances fun story a little
unserious in places but you know it was
pretty solid so that uh excellent a24
film that premiered last month it's
getting a wide theatrical release and
people are really loving it just
remember who liked it first
me everything everywhere all at once is
a runaway hit it's everywhere and
everyone loves it people are calling it
the best movie ever made which it makes
me want to just lower my original
positive rating this stupid childish
Reddit tier movie is now the highest
rated movie on letterbox which
watched it and reevaluated the picture I
have to give it half a star it's Oscar
season and some pretty boring movies are
taking over the conversation maybe it's
time to look back on that a24 movie you
know that everyone enjoys it's got way
more energy than half of these Front
Runners the actual worst movie ever made
is now the front runner in the Oscars
race I mean how are we talking about
this extended Rick and Morty episode
like it's a masterpiece it's Oscar's
night and you know what everything
everywhere all at once will probably
sweep all the awards and you know what
it's fine it's a good movie at least
it's not green book right I'm sure that
winning all of these Awards won't change
anyone's reaction to the film and oh
hold on uh they're announcing best
picture and the Oscar goes to everything
this is the worst and most overrated
movie in the history of motion picture